welcome to the making up for freak
guitar accident and today we're going to
go over something a little bit different
instead of showing you the vfx behind
this piece i'm going to show you how we
wrote the music and got niko's guitars
sounding really really awesome shredding
tips if you're using pre-made
royalty-free soundtracks usually they'll
do the job and set the tone but if you
want a piece that dynamically shifts
with everything happening on screen
you're going to need an original
soundtrack now there's a couple
applications you can use to do this all
of which have their own specialty fl
studio ableton those are great programs
if you want to do a lot of midi loop or
sample based work there's also programs
like pro tools that allow you to really
excel in doing live recording for your
pieces i personally use logic 9 because
it balances both really well i have a
lot of synthesizers and midi instruments
i can use as well as recording a lot of
live guitar and bass so when taking the
first steps of putting music into your
piece usually it's best to take the most
epic cool part of the song that you
enjoy and sync that up with a specific
scene that way you have a reference
point that you can work outwards with so
for free guitar accent that moment is
when nico first starts whipping out his
guitar and playing that first riff so
even if you're gonna have original music
in your piece it's best to have a
temporary track you put in there just so
you have a feel of the flow of the piece
it can be anything from just a song you
like to another movie's soundtrack but
just something that sets the atmosphere
and tone so you have something to edit
to for nightmare we use parts of the
lord of the rings soundtrack just
because i knew eventually i was going to
want to have a piece that sounded very
similar to that so how did i come up
with the song for free guitar accident
well i was sitting there trying to write
a couple riffs for the piece just seeing
what kind of stuff i could come up with
and eventually i kind of came upon an
old riff i had made for our band to keep
and it just kind of seemed to fit the
feel and the tone of it it was very it
was very heavy it was very melodic and
it uh it had a lot of good moments for
kind of soloing and guitar wankery so
for recording the piece i would play
guitar and bass and then i would use a
midi controller to play a sample drum
kit all these instruments i'd be running
through a lot of native instruments
plug-ins such as guitar rig and contact
so here's a couple tips on getting your
instruments to sound great firstly it's
all about layering almost every single
instrument i have playing in the song
has some sort of companion layer that
gives it a little extra kick and um for
drums i start with a normal kit i'm
playing on a midi controller i duplicate
the bass and snare and have those run
through like an 80s drum type sounding
sample and for the guitar one great
trick i like doing is offsetting the
layers a little bit that way you get a
really great stereo sound that really
brings the richness and fullness out of
it here's a quick run through of all the
layers i have going in the music i start
with the bass here which is the drum and
the kick
then i add real drums on top of that
[Music]
the bass comes in and follows the drums
very strongly
as well as the rhythm guitar
then i put the lead on top of that to
play the main melody
[Music]
now you'll notice that when i play each
section of the song you can still hear
the rest playing very clearly that's
because of mixing when mixing a song you
have to recognize that every single
instrument occupies a very specific
space in the mix for drums you have to
kick in the low end and the snare and
cymbals in the upper mids to highs i
like the bass guitar even lower than the
drums with a little bit of mids for
definition and so it doesn't compete i
bring down the lows and raise the mids
for the rhythm guitar and then for the
lead guitar i do the same while boosting
the highs even more
the key to this is that by not having
all your instruments overlapping and
occupying the same frequency your ears
are able to distinguish each one from
each other and brings the song a lot of
clarity that sometimes you wouldn't
otherwise get so i hope you guys learned
something from this video i'm also
uploading a multi-track of this song to
our server so you can download it and
listen to all the tracks that i used in
this song also if you haven't seen it
yet i've uploaded a guitar tab for this
song if you want to use the multi-track
and record your own version of it we'd
love to see what you guys come up with
if you guys have any questions of course
leave them in the comments box or send
us a tweet at
corridor digital right in front of my
face here nice and perfect all right
guys that's all
laters
[Music]
oh